so David in the last chapter that we
were looking at last time that we heard
fall celebrating the reality of God's
gracious gift drawing a typology or
comparison between Adam and Christ and
saying that the Christ's end of the
typology is so much more powerful than
they Adam more sinful end of the
typology so he was extending and
applying some of the insights that he
had started to develop in Chapter four
was also looking ahead a little bit to
his argument about the law and what role
the law plays in God's plan for
humankind what's going on in Chapter six
and how does it contribute to the
development of the argument
well let me easy to that kind of
indirectly my father was a preacher and
one of the things I always liked about
his preaching was that he could guess
what the congregation might be thinking
so he'd say now I know what you're
thinking when I say the following
and then he would kind of respond to
what he assumed was going on so I think
Paul here kind of imagines a
congregation what may be coming up in
the questioning of the people who's who
are hearing this claim and the first
thing he worries about is all right
we've just had this splendid affirmation
of the fact that we are saved by grace
not through anything we do that that our
sinfulness does not stay in the way of
kinds of God stand in the way of God's
graciousness well then there's that
there's the fraternity boys response hey
good news right sheer grace so if God is
gonna be gracious let's up the ante for
God and I will see in all the more so
the grace may be all the more impressive
and he wants to respond to that by
saying that's just a miss reading of
what the Christian faith is and briefly
of the first way in widgets of miss
reading is the Paul constantly returns
to the theme of what is the true
identity of the Christian and the claim
that we are to live that the believer
let's go back to that the believer is
supposed to live out that identity
faithfully and here as in Galatians and
in 1st Corinthians he wants to say a lot
of your identity has to do with your
baptism and that when you are baptized
into Christ you you put away that old
person that that sinful person who
rejoices in sin is no longer the real
you you had
to let that go and you are resurrected
at the end of that baptism process into
a new life in Jesus Christ so in in the
old slogan which i think is not bad Paul
is saying be who you are don't pretend
to be who you're not you are no longer
that sinful person you are now the
person who lives in Christ so live that
out and stop this nonsense about sinning
the more so Paul begins with one of
these rhetorical questions right
absolutely yeah yeah you pointed this
out what then are we just say I should
we continue in seeing in order that
grace may abound and you're suggesting
that he's anticipating a concern about
his own claim yeah I like that but I
wonder if there's something else going
on that people have actually said this
about you think so yeah that he's in
fact an anti no mian well he they're
mobitz in first corinthians i think
where one suspicion is in chapter 5
where the man is sleeping with his
stepmother where they may have said hey
since were saved by grace through faith
let's prove our Christian freedom and be
just as free as we can by the way
there's my stepmother mm-hmm let's see
what we can do about it so that maybe
he's still got maybe he's anxious about
the Corinthian problem which does come
awfully near to saying all right since
we're saved by grace anything goes right
especially if he wants to say that the
Torah is no longer binding yeah is what
does that mean yeah so if it's no longer
binding then does anything go and if
it's not the case that anything goes
what are the stipulations by which we
live the faithful life so in some ways
Paul wants to find a ground or a
framework for moral living yeah that
will substitute for or replace the the
Torah yeah and he finds it in Christ he
finds it in Christ and and in Baptism
which which strengthens that identity we
have with Christ so that in in a sense
if we said that for Paul faith is both
the faithfulness of Christ and the faith
of the believer baptism is the place
where the faithful believer lays hold of
the faithfulness of Christ and then
lives anew in that relationship in some
ways what Paul is doing sounds an awful
lot like certain kinds of ethical
thinking in the greco-roman doubt that
focus is on the virtuous individual that
one must
to imitate yeah to live the ethical life
I think of Aristotle II an economic unit
yeah thanks and so and in a sense Christ
becomes the virtuous individual whom we
virtuously imitate in a larger sense I
think Christ becomes the reality in
which we participate that it's not just
be like Christ it is that you are in
Christ and should you are I get up
tomorrow morning and say hi about a
little sin that's not just a mistake
that's a contradiction in terms that's a
that's a violation of our being you can
no more do that than announce that
you're gonna be I can't think of a
Zoroastrian tomorrow that's just not who
you are you are the Catholic Dean of the
Divinity School and that's not going to
change where you are also in Christ and
to pretend otherwise is to mistake
yourself not just a mistake faithfulness
so there's a virtue ethics going on here
but there's something else there's a
virtue ethics but there's something
beyond a virtue I think which is a kind
of participatory living out of what it
used to be Christ's body which we'll
look at again a little bit later in this
epistle I think about that thesis
statement again at the beginning of
Romans back there in chapter 1 that they
the gospel is the power of God
absolutely absolutely
so to be in the gospel is to be
empowered to be this different kind of
person and to fall back into sin is to
deny the very power by which you live
it's it's in the most literal sense
self-contradiction just not that it
contradicts itself but it contradicts
myself contradicts the self that I am in
Jesus I think there's also substantiates
what we were saying last time about at
the way in which paul uses different
kinds of metaphors to talk about this
reality and it's not simply
justification as a kind of imputed
righteousness that's at stake it's a
real process of transformation of the
human self through the power of God
absolutely and best as it becomes both
the symbol and the enactment of that I
think I'm a Baptist and I think we
sometimes make baptism much too weak
it's kind of a picture of something else
and for Paul it's the thing itself it's
the place in which you let go of that
old and lay hold of the new and become
that new person yeah is Paul's use of
the participant a participation language
here in his baptismal comment simple and
straightforward or the Scimitar esting
twists well I think the place where it's
the place where it's complicated for me
and then I loved here where it's
complicated for you is is often there in
his life and death language that in some
ways when we come out of baptism we we
move into the hope of new life at the
resurrection of the dead sometimes when
we come out of baptism we move into new
life right now and I think there's a
kind of tension in Paul all the way
through that to an extent we already
lived the life of faith open love to an
extent we wait for that in the
fulfillment of the consummation of what
God will do at the end of time and I
think in these little vs. at the
beginning of chapter 6 both those things
are going on yeah right so it's not a
simple use of this death in resurrection
it is not a simple use the the
resurrection thing has two meanings
simultaneously and I think I think again
to go back to our friends the
Corinthians I think at some points they
have simply said okay now I fully live
the resurrection life and there that
gives them an excuse to say once again
anything goes right and I don't leave my
safe through grace I live the
resurrection life so let's not worry
about little things like ethics morality
fidelity right Paul is really eager to
draw some ethical consequences
Paul is deeply concerned that the
faithful life is nonetheless an obedient
life and a life that that follows in
some ways classical virtues but not
always for classical reasons the notion
of the source of sin I think begins to
emerge here too in chapter 6 verse 12
therefore do not let sin exercise
Dominion in your mortal bodies to make
you obey their passion oh yeah
the passions or emotions the passions or
emotions are strong the way in which I
think I think what Paul believes of the
Christian person is that the Christian
person is not an autonomous person but a
kind of Chryst animus person that is the
Christian person lives in obedience to
Christ and that shapes her life his life
in powerful ways and that where we go
where we go astray is when we're ruled
by something other than Christ which can
be our passions or sin or striving or
boasting all those are false gods
because they they they're false Lords
their false masters will see even more
when he talked about in 15 should we sin
because we're not under the law but by
grace
do you not know verse 16 that if you
present yourselves to anyone as obedient
slaves you are slaves of the one you
obey either of sin which leads to death
or of obedience which leads to
righteousness we as Americans as
autonomous happy friendly Americans we
always think our freedom is freedom from
something and I think Paul it's much
more freedom for something that our
freedom is not in the fact we are not we
are not freed from obedience were freed
for obedience
it's interesting how Paul uses this
language of freedom and slavery and they
overlap and they do overlap that the
truth the proof freedom is slavery to
God that the false freedom is slavery to
sin or slavery to self or slavery to
flesh all of the languages you use to
show the ways in which we are mistaking
where our freedom lies it's what Martin
Luther picked up and liberty of the
Christian person where he wants to
insist that that true Liberty is is
always there in fidelity and loyalty to
God it is very different from our kind
of American Western let's be free of any
constrictions whatsoever and therefore
it's countercultural I am free because
I'm obedient to Christ what do you think
Paul is aware of the irony of the use of
his I think he must be I think he must
know that this is paradoxical or ironic
or that it lays off against it's
interesting again to think about some of
the greco-roman background of Paul's
Paul's terminology and you have similar
kinds of plays in among stoic exactly
the word freedom is is freedom from a
whole set of concerns and for Paul
that's really taking out a different set
of concerns and only they the wise man
is truly free even if he's a slaves
there's a different kind of iron totally
different kind of because here's who
it's to whom you are obedient to
determines your freedom there's also a
kind of social reality going on where
you know I think we we mistake the
connotations of slavery if we if we use
just the American experience those are
true because you could have in effect
high status slave yeah yeah yeah you
could right exactly so slavery does not
mean simply bossed around at all points
it can be a way of being in the
household right at the one to whom
you're slave also is your patron and
your sponsor if you were a slave of the
Emperor you could be a high civil
servant good effect yeah and if your
slave of God you could be a
that's right thanks that not a bad deal
yes indeed
all right thank you